in China a worryingly familiar scene a
food market shuttered an under
investigation
11 residential areas in southern Beijing
in lockdown virus free for almost 2
months now the city is facing a new
kovat 19 cluster the Fung ty district
has immediately launched a wartime like
response we have set up a field
headquarters to help seal off the shin
fonde wholesale market and the
surrounding communities one of the
biggest markets in Beijing the first new
case was linked to shin Fatih wholesale
site on Thursday 45 other workers and
visitors have now tested positive none
had symptoms several other markets have
also been closed as mass testing takes
place the pandemic was almost over and
then suddenly there's new hot spots I'm
a little scared when I saw the news I
really panicked but I thought it over
and it's not a big deal they'll seal off
the area so there shouldn't be a
large-scale outbreak after the initial
kovat 19 outbreak was linked to a market
in Wuhan China banned the trade capture
and consumption of wildlife this week
state media reported traces of the virus
were found on a salmon chopping board in
the market now authorities in Beijing
will carry out a complete safety
screening of the whole food industry in
an effort to prevent a second wave of
infection this particular market is a
very large one and so there's a lot of
people there just one case going into
the market which is semi-enclosed you
can imagine there could be transmission
onwards but I don't think the 50 cases
identified are the only infected people
in Beijing I think there'll be people
with infection in other parts of the
city and that will become clearer as
testing expands and more is done local
officials now say they're in emergency
mode tourism in the capital has been
temporarily banned plans for some
primary children to restart school
suspended
as Beijing battles to contain this new
corona virus outbreak
Siobhan Robbins Sky News